The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Welcome back.
So today we get to
finish our discussion
on at least the first wave
of value-based methods
for trying to find
optimal control
policies, without a model.
So we started last time talking
about these model-free methods.
And just to make sure
we're all synced up here,
so big picture is
that we're trying
to learn an optimal policy,
approximate optimal policy,
without a model, by just
learning an approximate value
function.
And the claim is that value
functions are a good thing
to learn for a
couple of reasons.
First of all, they
should describe
everything you need to know
about the optimal control.
Second of all, they're
actually fairly compact.
I'm going to say more
about that in a minute.
But if you think about it,
probably a value function
might actually be
a simpler thing
to represent than the policy, a
smaller thing to represent it,
because it's just a scalar
value over all states.
And the third big motivation
I tried to give last time
was that these temporal
difference methods which
bootstrap based on
previous experience,
they're, like value iteration
and dynamic programming,
can be very efficient in terms
of reusing the computation
or reusing the samples
that you've gotten by using
estimates that you've
already made with your value
function to make better,
fast estimates of your value
function as you [INAUDIBLE].
These are all going
to come up again.
But that's just the
high-level motivation
for why we care about trying
to learn value functions.
And then first thing
we did-- it was really
all we did last time.
The first thing
we had to achieve
was just estimate a value
function for a fixed policy,
which we called J pi, right?
And we did it just from
sample trajectories.
In discrete state and action,
we called them s and a.
Take a bunch of
trajectories, and you
would be able from
those trajectories
to try to back out J pi.
And those trajectories are
generated using policy pi.
So I actually tried to argue
that that was useful even
in the-- so if you just want--
if you have a robot out
there that's already
executing a policy, or a passive
walker or something like this
that doesn't have a
policy, and you just
want to see how well it's
doing, estimate its stability
by example, then
you can actually--
this might be enough for you.
You might just try to evaluate
how well that policy is doing.
We call that policy evaluation.
What we're actually
interested it's not that.
That's just the first step.
What we care about now is,
given if we can estimate
the value for a
stationary policy,
can we now do something
smarter and more involved,
and try to estimate what
the optimal value function.
Or you might think
of it as continuing
to estimate the value
function as we change
pi towards the [INAUDIBLE]
the optimal cost,
the optimal policy.
We talked about a couple of ways
to estimate the value function
for a fixed pi, right?
Even for function approximation,
we did first Markov chains,
and then we went to
function approximation.
And we have convergence
results for linear function
approximators.
And we went back and looked up
[INAUDIBLE] it had a question
about whether they used
lambda in your update,
if it always got to
the same estimate of J.
And I think the answer
was, yes, it always gets--
the convergence proof
has an error bound.
And that error bound
does depend on lambda,
if you remember
[INAUDIBLE] discussion.
But if you said your learning
rate gets smaller and smaller
and you go, it should converge
to the-- they should all
converge to the same
estimate of J pi.
So if you think about
it, learning J pi
shouldn't involve any
new machinery, right?
If I'm just experiencing cost,
and I'm experiencing states,
and I'm trying to learn a
function of cost-to-go given
states, that should just be able
to do a least squares function.
It's just a standard
function approximation task.
I could just do just a least
squares function approximation,
least squares
estimation, and what
we call the Monte-Carlo error.
Just run a bunch of
trials, figure out
the estimates of what the
cost-to-go was at every time,
and then just do least
squares estimation.
The machinery we
developed last time
was because it's actually
a lot faster using
bootstrapping algorithms.
[INAUDIBLE] much faster
than [INAUDIBLE]..
Right.
So we talked about the
TD lambda algorithm,
including for function
approximation.
The only reason we had to
develop any new machinery
is because we wanted to be able
to essentially do the least
squares estimation,
but we wanted
to reuse our current estimate
as we build up the estimate.
And that's why it's not just a
standard function approximation
task we did all the [INAUDIBLE]
something [INAUDIBLE]
presented it.
OK.
So that's the simple
policy evaluation story.
Now the question is, how
do we use the ability
to do policy evaluation to get
towards a more optimal policy?
So today, given the
new policy evaluation,
we want to improve the policy.
And the idea of this--
the first idea you have to
have in your head, very, very
simple.
And it's called
policy iteration.
So given I start off with some
initial guess for a policy,
and I run it for a little while,
I could do policy evaluation.
So I'm converged on a nice
estimate to get J pi 1.
And now I'd like to take
J pi 1, my estimate,
and come up with a new pi 2.
We've talked about how the
value function infers a policy.
And if I repeat, and
I do it properly,
then if all goes well,
I should find myself--
if it's always increasing
in performance,
and we can show that, then I
should find myself eventually
at the optimal policy and
optimal value function, right?
So we said TD lambda
was a candidate
for sitting there and
evaluating policy, which I've
talked about a couple
of different ways
to do policy evaluation.
So the question now is,
how do we this, then?
That's the first question.
So given your policy,
given your value function,
how do you compute
a new policy that's
at least as good as your
own policy but maybe better?
AUDIENCE: Maybe stochastic
gradient descent?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Do something like
stochastic gradient descent?
You have to be careful
with stochastic gradient.
You have to make sure
it's always going down,
and things like that.
It's a good idea.
In fact, that's sort of--
actually, [INAUDIBLE].
We combine stochastic gradient
descent and evaluation
to do actor-critic [INAUDIBLE].
But there's a
simpler sort of idea.
I guess the thing it requires--
I didn't even think about this
when I was making the notes.
But I guess it requires
an observation that--
so the optimal value function
and the optimal policy
have a property that
the policy is going,
taking the fastest descent
down the value function.
Your job is to go down the value
function as fast as possible.
But if you're not optimal yet,
I've got some random policy,
and I figure out my value of
executing that policy, that's
actually not true yet.
So what I need to say is, if
you start giving your value
function, you come up
with a new policy which
tries to be as
aggressive as possible
on this value function, which
in our continuous sense,
is going down the gradient
of the value function
as fast as possible.
And that should be
at least as good--
in the case of the optimal
policy, it should be the same.
It should return the
optimal policy again.
But in the case where the
value estimates from another,
original policy gets
you to do better.
So the basic story--
that's the continuous
gradient-- is
you want to come up with a
greedy policy that moves down,
that does the best it
can with this J pi.
So pi 2, let's say, which is
a function of s, should be,
for instance, [INAUDIBLE]
the discrete sense here,
discrete state and action,
minimize the expected value
[INAUDIBLE] expected value
first, by one-step error plus--
So I've got the cost
that I incur here
plus the long-term cost here.
I want to pick the
new min over a.
The best thing I can
do given that estimate
of the value function.
And that's going to give me
a new policy, actually, pi
2, which is greedy with respect
to this estimate of the value
function.
What does that look
like to you guys?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
OK.
So value iteration, or
dynamic programming,
is exactly policy
iteration in the case
where you do a sweep
through your entire state
space every time, and then you
update, sweep your entire state
space, you do the update.
Absolutely.
But it's a more general idea
than just value iteration.
You don't have to
actually evaluate all s.
You might call it
asynchronous value--
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't that
be argmin [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, good.
Thank you, yeah.
This is argmin.
Good catch.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is
like g [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
I always minimize this.
So g is [? bad. ?] Well, I
don't promise that I will never
make a mistake with
the signs, because I
try to use reinforcement
[INAUDIBLE] notation
with costs, and I can sometimes
get myself into trouble.
I never write "arg."
It's always g.
OK.
So so this would be argmin.
The min is the value estimated
in the case of value iteration.
But in general, you don't
have to wait till you
sweep the entire state space.
You can just take
a single trajectory
through, update
your value J. Or you
take lots of trajectories
through [INAUDIBLE]
get an improved estimate
for J, and then do this
and get a new policy, right?
In this policy iteration,
the original idea
is you should really do
this policy evaluation
step until your estimate of J pi
convergence, and then move on.
But in fact, value
iteration and other--
many algorithms
show that you can--
it actually is still
stable when you
don't wait for it to converge.
But there's a problem
with what I wrote here.
I don't think there's
a technical problem.
But why is that not quite what
we need for today's lecture?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just had
a quick question.
So if you're going to
be gradient with respect
to the value function
that you evaluate,
you can't do that
with a value function
if you have a model, right?
So you need a--
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
actually exactly--
you're answering the
question that I was asking.
That's perfect.
So from, as I said, model-free,
model-free, model-free,
but then I wrote
down a model here.
So how can I--
even in the steepest descent
sort of continuous sense,
this is absurd.
In the discrete
sense, argmin over a
is typically done with a
search over all actions
in the continuous
state and action.
I think it was finding the
gradient down the slope.
But right.
Both of those require
a model to actually do
that policy [INAUDIBLE].
So the first question
for today is,
how do we come up with
a gradient policy,
basically, without any model?
[INAUDIBLE] going to say it.
[INAUDIBLE] know
this, but that's the--
what do you think?
[INAUDIBLE] haven't read all
the [INAUDIBLE] algorithms.
What do you think?
What's the-- how
could I possibly
come up with a new policy
without having a model?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] s n plus
[INAUDIBLE] sample directly?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
You could sample.
You can start to do
some local search
to come up with [INAUDIBLE].
Turns out-- I mean,
I didn't actually
ask the question in a way that
anybody would have answered it
in the way I wanted, so.
So it turns out if
we changed the thing
we store just a little bit,
then it turns out to contribute
to do model-free greedy policy.
OK.
So the way we do
that is a Q function.
We need to find a Q function.
It's a lot like
a value function.
But now it's a function
of state and action.
And we'll say this is
still [INAUDIBLE] this way.
OK.
So what's a Q function?
A Q function is the
cost you should expect
to take, to incur, given
you're in a current state
and you take a
particular action.
So it's a lot like
a value function.
But now you're actually
learning a function
over both state and actions.
So in any state,
Q pi is the cost
I should expect to incur given
I take action a for one step
and I follow a policy pi
for the rest of the time.
That make sense?
So I could have my acrobot
controller or something
like this.
And in a current state, I've
got a policy that mostly gets me
up, but I'm learning more than
just what that policy would
do from this state.
I'm learning what
that policy would
have done if I had
for one step executed
any random action
on the function,
for any random action.
And then what would
I do from the--
beginning I ran that
controller for the rest of it.
Algebraically, it's going
to make a lot of sense
why we would store this.
But it's actually interesting
to think a little bit
about what that Q
function should look like.
And if you have a Q
function, you certainly
could also get the
value function,
because you can look up
for a given pi what action
that policy would have taken.
You can always pull out your
current value function from Q.
But you can also--
[INAUDIBLE] simple relationship
here in the [INAUDIBLE]..
And for the optimal
[INAUDIBLE],, I should actually
do that search over a.
I almost wrote minus.
That can be your
job for the day,
make sure I don't
flip any signs.
OK.
We're roboticists in this room.
What does it mean to
learn a Q function?
What are the implications
of learning a Q function?
Well, I guess I didn't say.
So given the Q function pi
[INAUDIBLE] having a Q function
makes action collection easy.
Pi 2 of s is now just a min
over a Q pi s and a, where
Q pi was [INAUDIBLE] with pi 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
argmin [INAUDIBLE]..
But I was willing to--
the reason to learn a
Q function in one case
here is that it tells me
about the other actions
I could have taken.
And if I want to now
improve my policy,
then I'll just look
at my Q function.
At every state I'm in, instead
of taking the one at pi a,
I'll go ahead and
take the best one.
If pi 1 was optimal,
that I would just
get back the same policy.
But if pi 1 wasn't
optimal, then I'll
get back something better, given
my current estimate of Q. OK.
But what does it mean to run Q?
And this is actually
all you need
to learn to do model-free value
[INAUDIBLE] optimal policy.
That's actually really big.
So it's a little
bit more to learn
than learning a value function.
And you're learning
about your [INAUDIBLE]..
If I had to learn J
pi, how big is that?
If I'm going to say
I've got n dimensional
states and m dimensional u--
I'll just think about
these two new cases,
even though [INAUDIBLE] this.
If I have to learn J
pi, how big is that?
What's that function
mapping for?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
scalar learning.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Learning
a scalar function over
the state space to R1, just
learning a scalar function.
If I was learning a policy,
how big would that be?
If I was learning a stationary
policy, it might be that.
So how bad is it to learn Q?
What's Q?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
asymptote [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Let's keep it a
deterministic policy for now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
Now I've suddenly got to
learn something over--
sorry, [INAUDIBLE] here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, there.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
And for [INAUDIBLE],,
what would it be
used to learn a modeled system?
If I wanted to use this idea.
What's that model?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
So f and then n plus m to Rn.
So let's just think about
how much you have to learn.
So the easiness of
learning this is not
only related to the size.
But it does matter.
So most of the time, as
control guys, as robotics guys
we would probably try to
learn a model first, and then
do model-based control.
The last few days
I've been saying,
let's try to do some things
without learning a model.
Here's one interesting
reason why.
It's actually-- learning a
model is sort of a tall order.
It's a lot to learn, right?
You've got to learn from every
possible state and action
what's my x dot [INAUDIBLE].
This is only learning from
every possible state and action.
What's the expected
cost-to-go [INAUDIBLE]??
[INAUDIBLE] a scalar.
So this is learning one
algorithm for all m.
And the beautiful thing
about optimal control,
with this sort of
additive cost functions
and everything like
that, the beautiful thing
is that this is all you need to
know to make optimal decisions.
You don't need to
know your model.
That model is extra information.
All you need to know to make
optimal decisions, given
these additive cost
functions [INAUDIBLE]
is given [INAUDIBLE] a state
and then a given action,
how much do I expect to
incur cost [INAUDIBLE]??
It's a beautiful thing.
So if we make it stochastic,
it gets even sort of--
learning a stochastic model,
if your dynamics are variable
and that's important,
you want to do
stochastic optimal control.
Learning a stochastic model is
probably even harder than that.
Maybe I have to
learn the mean of x
dot plus the covariance
matrix of x dot or something
like this.
When I use a
stochastic model, it
would be even more expensive.
Q, in the Q sense--
I left it off in the first
pass just to keep it clean,
but Q is just going to be the
expected value around this.
So Q is always going
to be a scalar, even
in the stochastic
optimal control sense.
So maybe this is the biggest
point of optimal control,
honestly--
optimal control
related to learning--
is that if you're willing to
do these additive expected
value optimization
problems, which
I think you've seen lots
of interesting problems
that fall into that
category, then all you
need to know to make decisions
is to be able to-- the value
function, the Q function here.
The expected value
of future penalties.
And for everything
else, [INAUDIBLE]..
Important point.
Now, just to soften it a
little bit, in practice,
you might not get
away with only that.
If you have to somehow build an
observer to do state estimation
or to estimate Q,
and you've got--
there might be other
reasons floating around
in your robot that might
require you to learn this.
But in a pure sense, that's
really what you need to know.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Russ?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You put x and u.
Shouldn't that be s and--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
We could have--
I could have said n is
the number of states.
AUDIENCE: I just meant,
should it be s and a?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
I would have--
I wrote the dimension of
x, and I called it Rn,m.
So that's what I meant.
If you want to make
an analogy back here,
then it would actually
be just the number
of elements in s and a.
But I wanted to sort of be
a roboticist [INAUDIBLE]
for a little bit.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: This is just
the computer scientist
that did this [INAUDIBLE].
But it does make this easier,
so I still [INAUDIBLE]..
So I meant to do that.
So that [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So now, how do we learn Q?
I told you how to learn J.
Q looks pretty close to J.
How do I learn Q?
I told you about temporal
different learning,
probably wouldn't
have wasted your time
talking about
temporal difference
learning if it
wasn't also relevant
for what we needed to do these
model-free value methods.
So let's just see that temporal
difference learning also
works for learning
these functions.
OK?
That's just some [INAUDIBLE].
Let's do just a
simple case first,
where I'm just doing-- remember,
TD0 was just bootstrapping.
It wasn't carrying
around long-term rewards.
It was just saying
[INAUDIBLE] one step,
and then I'm going to use my
value estimate for the rest
of the time as my new update.
And I'll go ahead, since we're--
we talked about last time
how a function approximator
[INAUDIBLE] reduce it to
the Markov chain case,
let's just do it like--
let's say [INAUDIBLE] of s is
alpha i phi i, linear function
approximators.
Or we could, in fact,
reduce alpha t phi s, a.
OK.
Then the TD lambda
update it going to be--
TD0 update is just
going to be alpha
plus gamma call that hat
just to be careful here--
pi s transpose.
These really are supposed
to be s n and a n.
I get a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
for my sloppy [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
And Q pi-- or the gradient
here in the linear function
approximator case,
is just phi s, a.
So if you look back
in your notes, that's
exactly what we had before,
where this used to be J.
We're going to use
is our new update--
we're going to say that
our new estimate for J
is basically the one-step cost
plus the long-term look-ahead.
a n plus 1 in the case
of doing an on-policy--
if I'm just trying to
do policy evaluation,
it's going to be pi s n plus 1.
We'll use that
one-step prediction
minus my current prediction
and try to make that go to 0.
And in order to do it in a
function approximator sense,
that means multiplying that
error, the temporal difference
error, by the gradient.
And that was something
like gradient descent
on your temporal
difference policy.
But not exactly, because it's
this whole recursive dependence
thing.
People get why-- do
people get that it's not
quite gradient descent
but kind of this?
This looks a lot
like what I would
get if I was trying to do
gradient descent [INAUDIBLE],,
right?
But only in the case of TD1
was actually gradient descent.
But normally if I
have a y minus f of x,
I'm trying to do the gradient
with respect to this,
I've got to minimize this.
And I'll get something-- if I
take the gradient with respect
to alpha, I get the error
alpha x [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Because what we
got here, this is our error.
If we assume that this
is just my desired
and this is my actual, then
this is gradient descent.
But it's not quite that, because
this depends on an alpha--
these all depend on alpha.
So by virtue of having
this one in the alpha,
it's not exactly gradient
descent algorithm.
But it still works.
People proved that it works.
Is that OK?
And actually, in the
case where TD is one,
these things actually
go through it
and cancel each other out with
whatever is a gradient descent
algorithm [INAUDIBLE].
But I want you to
see, this is my error
I'm trying to make Q and
my current state and action
look like my one-step cost plus
Q of my next state and action.
And I would do that by
multiplying my error
by my gradient in a gradient
descent kind of idea.
OK.
You can still do TD
lambda if you like also.
Q functions And
the big idea there
was to use an
eligibility trace, which
in the function
approximator case,
was gamma lambda ei
n plus [INAUDIBLE]..
And then my update
is the same thing--
alpha-- because this is my
big temporal difference error.
And instead of multiplying
by the gradient [INAUDIBLE]
this eligibility trace.
And magically through
an algebraic trick,
remembering the gradient
computes the bootstrapping case
when lambda is 0, and the Monte
Carlo case when lambda is 1,
and something in between
when lambda is [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So you'd still do
temporal difference there.
Big point number two--
big idea number one is we
have to use Q functions to do
action selection.
Big point number two is
off-policy policy evaluation.
Once we start using Q,
you could do this trick
that I mentioned first thing
we're doing value methods.
And that is to execute policy pi
1 but learn Q pi 2 [INAUDIBLE]..
Can you see how we do that?
By virtue of having
this extra dimension,
we know we're
learning-- bless you--
not only what happens when I
take policy pi from state s.
I'm learning what happens when
I take any action in state s.
That gives me a lot more power.
Because for instance, when I'm
making my temporal difference
error, I don't need
to necessarily use
my one-step prediction
as the current policy.
I can just look up what
would policy 2 [INAUDIBLE]..
Because I'm storing
every state-action pair,
it's more to learn, more work.
But it means I can say,
I'd like my new Q pi 2
to be the one-step policy
I got from taking a plus
the long-term cost of
taking policy pi 2.
And then all the same equations
play out, and you get--
you get an estimate
for policy 2.
AUDIENCE: Does it count--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does it count
more than the first step
of the policy 2 and then take
your cost-to-go of policy 1?
Or does it somehow--
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
I can't switch--
we'll talk about whether you
can switch halfway through.
But once I commit
to learning Q pi 2,
then actually this
whole thing is built up
of experience of
executing policy 2,
even though I've only generated
sample paths for policy 1.
So it's a completely consistent
estimator of Q pi 2, right?
If I halfway through
decided I wanted
to start evaluating
pi 3, then I'm
going to have to wait
for those cancel out,
or we play some
tricks to do that.
But it actually
recursively builds up
in the estimator of pi 2.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Of course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] have that
[INAUDIBLE] function like this,
we can substitute y--
RUSS TEDRAKE: You're
talking about this?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
You can substitute y
by [? g or ?] gamma,
and then execute the--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
take the derivative?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: So why isn't
it true gradient descent?
That's exactly what
I proposed to do.
But the only problem is,
this isn't what we have.
What we actually
have is this, which
means that this is not the
true gradient [INAUDIBLE] term
for partial y partial
from over here.
AUDIENCE: That's
what I'm suggesting.
So instead of y alpha, we
can actually [INAUDIBLE]
g plus gamma-- an
approximation of y.
So this g plus gamma
Q is [INAUDIBLE]
approximation for y, right?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm
trying to perfectly make
the analogy that this looks like
that, and this looks like that.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But when we're taking the
derivative from that function,
we assume that y is constant.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then solve this.
AUDIENCE: We can actually assume
that y is dependent on alpha
and the derivative of that term
with respect to alpha as well,
and then solve it.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
So you could do that.
So you're saying why
don't we actually have
a different update which has
the gradient [INAUDIBLE]??
OK, good.
So in the case of TD0--
TD1, you actually do have that.
And I think that's true.
I worked this out a
number of years ago.
But I think it's true that
if you start including that,
if you look at the sum over a
chain, for this standard update
with TD0, for instance,
that those terms,
this term now will actually
cancel itself out on this term
here, for instance.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't work nicely.
It would give you-- it gives
you back the Monte Carlo error.
It doesn't do
temporal difference.
It doesn't do the bootstrapping.
So basically, you
start including that,
then you do get a least
squares algorithm, of course.
But it's effectively
doing Monte Carlo.
You have to sort of ignore
that do to temporal difference
learning.
You're actually saying, I'm
going to believe this estimate
in order to do that.
OK?
Temporal difference,
if you actually
want to prove any
of these things,
I have one example
of it in the note.
I think that I put in TD1 is
gradient descent in the notes,
just so you see an example.
A story-- rule of the game in
temporal difference learning,
derivations, and proofs, is
you start expanding these sums,
and terms from time
n and terms from time
n plus 1 cancel each other
out in a gradient way.
And you're left with
something much more compact.
That's why [? everybody ?]
calls it an algebraic trick, why
these things work.
But because these are not random
samples drawn one at a time,
they're actually
directly related
to each other, that's why it
makes it more complicated.
OK.
So we said off-policy
evaluation says,
execute policy pi 1 to get pi 1
generates s n a n trajectories.
But you're going to do
the update alpha plus--
I'm going to just write quickly
here-- g s, a plus gamma Q pi--
this is going to be
estimator Q pi 2--
s n plus 1 pi 2.
What would pi 2 have done
in kind of s n plus 1?
In general, we'll multiply
it by [INAUDIBLE]..
That's a really,
really nice trick.
Let's learn about
policy 1-- or policy 2
while we execute policy 1.
OK.
So what policy 2
should we learn about?
And again, these are--
I'm asking the questions
in bizarre ways,
and there's a specific answer.
But [INAUDIBLE]
ask that question.
Our ultimate goal
is not to learn
about some arbitrary pi 2.
I want to learn about
the optimal policy.
I don't have the optimal policy.
But I have an estimate of it.
So actually, a perfectly
reasonable update
to do, and the way you might
describe it is, let's execute--
I'm putting it in
quotes, because it's not
entirely accurate, but
it's the right idea--
execute policy 1 but learn
about the optimal policy.
And how would we do that?
Well-- this is now my
shorthand Q star here.
Estimate of Q star
is s n plus 1--
I should have--
It makes total sense.
Might as well, as
I'm learning, always
try to learn about policy
which is optimal with respect
to my current
estimate J [? hat. ?]
And this algorithm
is called Q-learning.
OK.
It's the crown jewel of
the value-based methods
[INAUDIBLE].
I would say it was the gold
standard until probably about
[? '90-- ?] something like that.
When people started to do policy
gradient stuff more often.
Even probably halfway
through the '90s,
people were still mostly
[INAUDIBLE] papers
about Q-learning.
and there was a movement
in policy gradient.
AUDIENCE: So is your
current estimate
Q star not based on pi 1?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It is
based on data from pi 1.
But if I always make my
update, making it this update,
then it really is
learning about pi 2.
AUDIENCE: Isn't pi 2 what you're
computing with this update?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
There's a couple of
ways that I can do this.
So in the policy--
in the simple
policy iteration, we
use [INAUDIBLE] evaluate
for a long time,
and then you make an, update,
you evaluate for a long time,
and you make an update.
AUDIENCE: This is dynamically--
RUSS TEDRAKE: This is always
sort of updating, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
And you can prove that it's
still a sound algorithm
despite [INAUDIBLE].
This is always sort of
updating its policy as it goes.
Compared to this,
which is more of the--
learn about pi 2 for a
while, stop, [INAUDIBLE]
pi 3 for a while,
stop, this is trying
to go straight through pi.
OK, good.
So what is it--
what's required for a Q-learning
algorithm to converge?
So even for this algorithm to
converge, in order for pi 1
to really teach me everything
there is to know about pi 2,
there's some important feature,
which is that pi 1 and pi 2
had better pick the same actions
with some old probability.
So off-policy works.
Let's just even think about--
I'll even [INAUDIBLE] first in
the discrete state and discrete
actions and the Markov--
MDP formulations.
Off-policy works if pi 1 takes
in general all state-action
pairs with some
small probability.
If pi 2 took action [INAUDIBLE]
state 1 and pi 1 never did,
there's no way I'm
going to learn really
what pi 2 is all about.
[INAUDIBLE] show you
those two [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So how do you do that?
If you just-- if you're
thinking about greedy policies
on a robot, and you've got your
current estimate of the value,
and you do the most aggressive
action on the acrobot,
I'll tell you what's
going to happen.
You're going to visit the
states near the bottom,
and you start learning a lot.
And you're never going to
visit the states up at the top
when you're learning.
So how are you going to get
around that on the acrobot?
And the acrobot is
tough, actually.
But the idea is, you'd
better add some randomness
so that you explore more
and more state and actions.
And the hope is that if you add
enough for a long enough time,
you're going to learn
better and better policies,
you're going to find
your way up to the top.
So the acrobot is
actually almost as hard
as it gets with these
things, where you really
have to find your
way into this region
to learn about the region.
In fact, my beef with
reinforcement learning
community is that
they learn only
to swing up to some threshold.
They never actually
[INAUDIBLE] to the top.
If you look, there's lots
of papers, countless papers,
written about reinforcement
learning, Q-learning
for the acrobot and
things like this,
and they never actually
solve the problem.
They just try to
[INAUDIBLE] at the top.
But they don't do it.
They just get up this high.
Because it is sort
of a tough case.
So how do you do this?
So you get-- like
I said, in order
to start exploring
that space, you'd
better add some randomness.
So one of the
standard approaches
is to use epsilon
greedy algorithms.
So I said, let's make pi 2
exactly the minimizing thing.
That's true.
But if you execute that, you're
probably going to [INAUDIBLE]
much better to
execute a policy pi s,
where the-- let's say
the policy I care about,
I'm going to execute
with probability--
sort of, you flip a coin,
you pull a random number
between 0 and 1.
If it's greater
than epsilon, then
go ahead and execute
policy you're
trying to learn
about, but execute
some random action otherwise.
OK.
So every time I--
every dt I'm going to
flip a coin, keep it--
well, not a coin.
A hundred-sided coin, a 100 to--
0 to 1, a continuous thing.
If it comes out
less than epsilon,
I'm going to do a random action.
Just forget about my current
policy, pick a random action.
It's a uniform
distribution over actions.
Otherwise, I'll take this,
the action from my policy.
And by virtue of having a
soft policy learning thing
is I can still learn
about pi 2, even
if I'm taking this pi epsilon.
But I have the
advantage of exploring
all the state-actions.
Good.
I'm missing a page.
AUDIENCE: Is that
the most randomness
you can produce since
they'll [INAUDIBLE] converge?
RUSS TEDRAKE: There's a couple
of different candidates.
The softmax is another
one that people use a lot.
And a lot of--
I mean, in the off-policy sense,
it's actually quite robust.
So a lot of people talk about
using behavioral policy, which
is just sort of something
to try-- it's designed
to explore the state space.
Actually, my candidate
for behavioral policy
is something like RRT.
We should really
try to do something
that gets me into all areas
of state space, for instance.
And then maybe that's
a good way to design,
to sample these
state-action pairs.
And all the while, I
try to learn about pi 2.
So it is robust in that sense.
When I say it works here, I
have to be a little careful.
This is only for the MDP
case that it's really
guaranteed to work.
There's more recent work
doing off-policy and function
approximators.
And you can do that.
I don't want to bury you
guys with random detail.
But you can do off-policy with
linear function approximators
safely, using an important
[INAUDIBLE] when you're dealing
[INAUDIBLE].
And that's work by Doina Precup.
The basic idea is you have to--
if your policy is changing,
like these things,
it's changing over time, you'd
better weight your updates
based on the relative--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
necessarily.
But that's--
RUSS TEDRAKE: But what you're
learning about is the state--
the probability of picking
this action for one step
and then executing pi 2.
And that's still [INAUDIBLE]
even pi 2 would never
take that action.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
Because it's-- OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
I think it's good.
The thing that has to
happen is that pi 2
has to be well-defined
for every possible state.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So keeping the Q pi 2 is
take a certain [INAUDIBLE]
take certain action, then
[INAUDIBLE] pi [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sorry, I lost that [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, good.
Sorry.
Thank you for clarifying it.
Yeah, so cool.
So I think that still works.
OK.
So this is good.
So let me tell you
where you are so far.
We've now switched from doing
temporal difference learning
on value functions and
temporal difference
learning on Q functions.
And a major thing
we got out of that
was that we can do this
off-policy learning.
You put it all together.
[INAUDIBLE] back into my
policy iteration diagram,
and what we have, we've defined
the policy evaluation, that's
the TD lambda.
We defined our
update, which could
be this in the general sense.
This one is-- if
I used pi 1 again,
If I really did on-policy,
if I used pi 1 everywhere
while I'm executing
pi 1, then this
would be called SARSA,
[INAUDIBLE] sort
of on-policy Q-learning,
on-policy updating.
And Q-learning is this, where
you use the middle gradient.
And what we know, what
people have proven,
the algorithms were in use
for years and years and years
before it was actually proven,
even in the tabular case,
where you have finite
state and actions.
But now we know that
this thing is guaranteed
to converge to the
optimal policy,
that policy iteration, even
if it's updated at every step,
is going to converge
to the optimal policy
and the optimal
Q function, given
that all state-action pairs
are [INAUDIBLE] in the tabular
case.
If we go to function
approximation,
if you just do policy
evaluation but not update,
then we have an example
where this is actually
in '02 or something like that.
It'd be '01 or '02, 2001.
We finally proved that
off-policy with linear function
approximation would converge
when the policy is not
changing--
no control.
So the thing I need to
give you before we consider
this a complete story here is,
can we do off-policy learning?
Can we do our
policy improvement,
update stably with
function approximation?
And the algorithm
that we have for that
is our least squares
policy iteration.
Do you remember least squares
temporal difference learning?
Sort of the idea was that if we
look at the stationary update--
maybe I should
write it down again.
[INAUDIBLE] find it.
If I look at the
stationary update,
if I were to run an
entire batch of--
I mean, the big idea is when
you're doing the least squares,
is that we're going to
try to reuse old data.
We're not going to just make
a single update, spit it
out, throw9t away.
We're going to remember a bunch
of old state-action pairs,
trying to make a least squares
update with just the same thing
as [INAUDIBLE].
In the Monte Carlo
sense, it's easy.
It's just function
approximation,
where with this TD term
floating around it's harder.
So we had to come up least
squares temporal difference
learning.
And in the LSTD
case, the story was
we could build up a matrix using
something that looked like phi
of s gamma phi transpose--
so it's ik.
Let me just write ik in here--
ik plus 1 minus phi of ik.
times my parameter vector.
And b-- some of
these terms was e,
which were phi ik times
our reward times--
And if I did this least
squares solution--
or I could invert that
carefully with SVD or something
like that--
then what I get out is the--
it jumps immediately to
steady-state solution TD
lambda.
So this is essentially
the big piece
of the TD lambda update
broken into the part that
depends on alpha, the part
that doesn't depend on alpha.
I could write my
batch TD lambda update
as alpha equals alpha
plus gamma a alpha plus b.
And I could solve that at
steady-state [INAUDIBLE]..
All right.
So least squares policy, least
squares temporal difference
learning, is about reusing
lots of trajectories
to make a single update that was
going to jump right to the case
where the temporal difference
learning we've gotten through.
We just replayed it
a bunch of times.
Now the question
is, the policy is
going to be moving
while we're doing this.
How can we do this sort
of least squares method
to do the policy
iteration up here?
Again, the trick
is pretty simple.
We've just got to learn
the Q function instead,
[INAUDIBLE] biggest trick.
So in order to do--
control not just
evaluate a single policy
but actually try to
find the optimal policy,
first thing we have
to do is figure out
how to do LSTD on a Q function.
And it turns out it's no--
yeah, what's up?
[INAUDIBLE]
It turns out if you
keep along, [INAUDIBLE]
exactly the same form as
we did in least squares
temporal difference learning,
but now we do everything
with functions of s and t.
[INAUDIBLE] transpose on it.
Now I do the--
you said form of the
[INAUDIBLE] too much.
I just want you to
know the big idea here.
Then I do gamma
[INAUDIBLE] a inverse b,
this whole time we're
representing our Q function.
Q hat s, a is now a linear
combination of nonlinear basis
functions on s and a.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't that
be transpose [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: I put--
I tried to put a
transpose with my poorly--
throughout everything.
So you're saying this one
shouldn't be transpose?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
should be a [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
Good.
So I'm going to--
but this one, I wrote
this whole update
as the transpose of the
other-- of what I just
wrote over there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
write alpha?
[INAUDIBLE] If it was
a plus b some stuff?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah.
And there's an alpha, sorry.
Thank you.
Well, actually, it's-- the
alpha is really not there.
Yeah, I should have
written it here.
It's a times alpha.
That's what it
makes the update on.
So we get [INAUDIBLE] alpha.
So that is actually [INAUDIBLE].
This is the one I
did [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, good.
So it turns out you can
learn a Q function just
like you can learn
a value function,
with storing up
these matrices, which
are what TD learning would
have done in a batch sense,
and then just taking
a one-step shot
to get directly to the solution
for temporal difference
learning for Q function.
And again, I put
in here s prime.
And I left this a
little bit ambiguous.
So I can evaluate any
policy by just putting
in that policy in here
and doing the replay.
And it turns out if I now do
this in a policy iteration
sense, LSPI--
Least Squares Policy Iteration--
basically, you start off
with an initial guess,
we do LSTDQ [INAUDIBLE]
to get Q pi 1.
And then you repeat, yeah?
Then this thing, that's
enough to get you to--
it converges.
Now, be careful about
how it converges.
It converges with some error
bound to pi star Q star.
The error bound depends
on a couple of parameters.
So technically, it could
be close to your solution
and oscillate, or
something like that.
But it's a pretty strong
convergence result
for this for policy improvement
with approximate value
function.
In a pure sense, it is--
you should run this
for a while until you
get a good estimate for LSTD
and you get your new Q pi.
But by virtue of using Q
functions, when you do switch
to your new policy,
pi 2, let's say,
you don't have to throw
away all your old data.
You just take your old tapes
and actually regenerate a and b
as if you had played off
those old tapes with--
as if you had seen the old
tapes executing the new policy.
And you can reuse
all your old data
and make an efficient update
to get Q pi [INAUDIBLE]..
Least squares policy iteration.
Pretty simple.
OK.
I know that was a little dry
and a little bit-- and a lot.
But let's make sure we know
how we got where we got.
So there's another route
besides pure policy search
to do model-free learning.
All you have to do is take
a bunch of trajectories,
learn a value function
for those trajectories.
You don't even actually
have to take the perfect--
your best controller yet.
You could take some RRT
controller, something that's
going to explore the space and
try to learn about your value
function.
Learn Q pi through
these LSTD algorithms,
you could do a pretty efficient
update for doing Q pi.
You can improve efficiently
by just looking over
the min over Q,
and pretty quickly
iterate to an optimal
policy and optimal value
function, only storing--
the only thing you have to
store in that whole process
is the Q function.
And in the LS case, the LSTD
case, you remember the tape--
the history of tapes, just
you use them more efficiently.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So could you have
used this on the flapper
that John showed?
Or what's the--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
Very good question.
That's an excellent question.
So in fact, the last day of
class, what we're going to do
is going to--
the last day I present in
class, we're going to--
I'm going to go through
a couple of sort
of case studies and
different problems
that people have had
success and tell you
why we picked the algorithm
we picked, things like that.
So why didn't we do
this on a flapper?
The simplest reason is that
we don't know the state space.
It's infinite
dimensional in general.
So that would have
been a big thing
to represent a Q function for.
It doesn't mean-- it
doesn't make it invalid.
We could have
learned, we could have
tried to approximate the state
space with even a handful
of features, learned a very
approximate Q function,
and done something
like actor-critic
like we're going
to do next time.
But I think in cases where you
don't know the state space,
or the state space is
a very, very large,
and you can write a
simple controller,
then it makes more sense
to parameterize the policy.
It really goes down to that
game, that accounting game,
in some ways, of how many
dimensions things are.
But in a fluids case, you could
have a pretty simple policy
from sensors to actions
which we could twiddle.
We couldn't have an
efficient value function.
Now, there are other cases
where the opposite is true.
The opposite is true, where
you have a small state space,
let's say, but the
resulting policies
would require a lot of
features to parameterize.
But I think in general, the
strength of these algorithms
is that they are efficient
with reusing data.
The weakness is that--
well, the weakness
a few years ago
would have been that they
big blow up the time.
But algorithms have gotten
better as we [INAUDIBLE]
we have some
convergence guarantees.
Not the general [INAUDIBLE].
I never told you
that it converged
if you have a nonlinear
function approximator.
We'd love to have that
result [INAUDIBLE]..
We won't have it for a while.
But in linear function
approximator sense,
we have both.
But there's a lot
of success stories.
These are the kind of
algorithms that we're
used to play backgammon.
There are examples
of them working
on things like the [INAUDIBLE].
But in the domains that I
care about most in my lab,
we tend to do more policy
gradient sort of things.